in town after War ravaged Town Rubble
fil streets people once
strolled homes bear the scars of War
ghost towns near the front
line they may seem abandoned but the hum
of a generator people talking reveal
life is carrying on
underground as you can see we're being
shelled constantly we tell people not
stay outside in groups they should stay
indoors or come here people are living
in other basements around the city but
then not as safe as this
one offering Public Services albe it's
scaled down is about preserving dignity
something War strips away a moment to
reflect brings back a memory of a friend
he
says who died exactly one year ago to
the
day this is one of the only buildings in
town that still has running water which
means there are hot showers and over
here uh there is a fully functioning
laundromat service and if you you walk
into the next room it's an entertainment
space and it has a makeshift Cinema
there's Books and Music there's a store
where you can get snacks and hot coffee
all of this is quite impressive it's
more than just Creature Comforts here it
is a luxury considering we're just about
a kilometer from Ukrainian trench
positions a little bit of normal life in
the middle of War a place to see friends
get rations a hot drink
to get and give help to avoid being
alone in the worst of
times to be honest I cry in what remains
of my apartment I had a life there I had
friends I had family of course it's not
a mansion but it was mine right now I'm
like a dog with a back in a field here
with people I forget about that a
little people say they are used to
living near the front line but the
sounds of shelves never stops being
scary
in a place like this every life becomes
precious even the local animal shelter
is still open for business still
treating sick pets but everyone here
knows all roads South lead to Russian
positions to danger and simply to remain
is to resist Zan basravi Al jazer Julia
POA Ukraine southern zapia region